now that I've been on this [ __ ] diet
because I'm trying to lose weight I'm
just doing a diet yeah but what is a
diet just saying
his eyes might die I mean you're saying
you're about I don't eat sweets unless
it's dessert
diet okay okay so now you're on a diet
what we're gonna complain about I was
gonna do it okay listen
[Laughter]
a life without sugar is is not a life
worth living I thought that on the way
to work today as I'm sipping a [ __ ]
cortado with no sugar in it and nothing
and I'm just like I feel like I'm living
in black and white I feel like it's dull
like everything is dull like sugar is
the greatest thing that God has ever
gods have ever given us the gods see
that how's the dragons right
yeah
[Music]
but it is the most amazing thing and the
cultures that have sugar happiest
cultures where does sugar come from
sugar cane and where are they my sugar
cane Hawaii like the islands the islands
have you is there terrorism on islands
is there anything angry or their Revolt
is there anything no in Haiti
yeah
the poorest country in the world
sword fights sword fights yeah clay food
do you know what I mean yeah if they had
Muslims
what I'm trying to say Cubans are living
in communism dancing through it yeah
it is sugar yes yes is the key louder
louder Vikings is there sugar no sugar
no angry angry people pillage rape rape
pillage Lebanon was the Paris of the
Middle East why the [ __ ] do you think
Mark the sugar Christianity but okay
listen to your question you misled me is
the sugar of religion religion
right what is Hinduism Hinduism is uh
mud why not the spice spice is right
there you're [ __ ] right yeah
sugar anyway profile listen my point is
that's on Dub's Tesla camera outside
sugar life is useless without sugar
uh-huh useless but mostly human
existence without sugar that's and it's
not true no I'd also like to point out
something
also yes it did something yeah what was
fun about history when do you look back
and say hey that looks fun and don't
bring race into it oh
like a fun time to be alive you would
try exclude race I'm just saying yeah
[Applause]
we also have a good point there are two
good points dude
's history no diversity how so
no plane no boat
way too far you did something [ __ ] up
in your town yeah you need a land bridge
or something yes yeah okay sugar
keeps people together it unites people
it makes them happy another thing I'd
like to point out we've looked at back
and oh there's no food no food I don't
think there was no food
I think now there's less food for poor
people than there was back in the day
okay how about how I don't think people
starve back then because you wouldn't
have religions that limited diet if
there were people starving but every
religion has these limitations with diet
that's not something that you bestow on
a people that are starving they're
incentivizing diets so people don't kill
themselves they go no no your suffering
is good you'll go to heaven what the
[ __ ] did that just mean I'm saying when
there's no food and they're like hey I'm
starving and they're like no you're not
starving going against his religion
which I'm still trying to figure out
right now explain that it's awesome
always defends religion and now he's
saying oh religion is just there's
people and kill themselves so they made
up fake rules oh you're saying religion
is manipulating the weird thing you said
that was weird
but you see what he did right he was
like they want to manipulate them
no he's not
[Laughter]
so what happened Mark Christianity just
made up diets to control the masses I
recognize that historical religions are
probably used to organize Society even
though God exists just because God's the
author of creation doesn't mean he's not
going to create things that make sense
within our modern world
it didn't even make sense the last of
this last science of religion are not at
odds because God made both nobody's say
anything about scientists we're talking
about sugar yeah
you're bringing a scientist no I know
I'm sorry I'm sorry uh but miles do you
have some boring things to say
listen listen no fasting I'm talking
about the Jews out here had so much food
they're like well don't eat the Bottom
Feeders yeah don't eat pork don't eat
these things those things got you sick
back in the day no they didn't that's
cat no they did there was so much food
they got to be like well I don't want
that little bottom [ __ ] what I mean I
don't want pigs they're eating off the
ground I want fancy food like deer do
you know what I'm saying they could be
booty about their food because there was
so much [ __ ] food now we got
overfishing ain't no fish in the sea
back in the day she was full of fish you
couldn't even swim surfing didn't even
get invented until 300 years there's no
ways
you know why there was no ways it was
just fishing it was full of waves
water's just gone you just walk on water
walk on fish yeah he was walking on fish
that's how much fish there was that's
why it was easy he was just stopping
from fish head to fish it exactly lily
pads fish all right guys we're gonna
take a break from this exclusive patreon
clip because I gotta make sure you don't
tear up your lungs and you're gonna do
that with the freeze pipe okay the best
bongs in the [ __ ] business look
at this not only are they beautiful
impressive okay you ask a chick to come
over you pull out one of these she don't
know what to do she don't know what to
do you ask a dude to come over maybe
you're trying to hook up with a dude
ladies or fellas you know what I mean
you bust out one of these he might sit
on it that's how comfy these are and he
doesn't even know about the glycerin
chambers that make it extra cool why do
you think they call it the freeze pipe
that smoke is extra cool coming into
your throat and lungs okay fast forward
it's sliding down your throat into your
lungs fast forward with the freeze pipe
because the freeze pipe has got your
back them glycerin Chambers I'm telling
you you never had smoke this cold okay
you're not going to be coughing throat
on fire you're gonna be taking the
biggest bong rips you've ever taken your
life thank God to the freeze pipe they
got it and they got your back okay so
for the smoothest glass pieces at every
day great prices go to thefreeze
pipe.com use the code flagrant you're
gonna get 15 off your order that's the
freezepipe.com use the code flagrant for
15 off shop today your throat and your
lungs well thank you now let's get back
to this exclusive patreon clip you could
join the [ __ ] Army and you should at
patreon.com there was no pollution to
kill animals nothing how many species
are endangered now so many how many were
in danger back then none none thank you
thank you dodo birds dodo birds were not
delicious enough to be eaten by the
prehistoric or whatever people they wear
whatever what do you call you the people
you guys believe in their their rules
you know biblical folks oh yeah you know
what I'm saying all I'm saying is I
think it's very very realistic that this
idea we have in the past that people are
like starving to death
also the Potato Famine look at it
trout that's a good point trouten it
wasn't a trout famine right what about
the fish they're living in the middle of
the country they can't get out to the
coast
uh we are Lake people I'm Scottish we go
into the lake we get to get food out of
the lake this idea that the Irish were
dying because there's no potatoes oh
[ __ ] a little laptop right yes
why would we limit diet for starving
people yeah that's a good point I even
think Muhammad says that if you are
starving you can relinquish the rules of
Islam you can eat whatever it is to
sustain yourself that was very powerful
of him that's sensible
thank you you know what I mean they
couldn't fish because they were starving
there was they had no energy to fall
it's not like such a [ __ ]
explanation that sounds like that sounds
like procrastinating to me no that's
from Deep now
I'm sorry get out of here is it helpful
extremely helpful thank you
all I'm trying to say is I think people
are more starving now than they used to
be well there's well there's maybe
there's maybe Merit to that there's a
lot more people you said there's less
food not that many people not that many
people so there's more food because
there's less people now was it harder to
catch food that was such a stupid are
you my wife roll in your [ __ ] eyes
I'll slap you in your face dude I can't
do it to her I'll give to you what did I
make a face I say something logical and
they just
all right [ __ ] what's this about I
didn't even roll my eyes my eyebrow came
down and covered my whole eyes that's
what I did I've been closing my eyes to
role models in my life I go like this
no clue what's happening roll them down
that [ __ ] is even more of you oh you
ever did I just looked at my nose
my nose so big I don't even have to be
cockeyed to look at my [ __ ] you know how
they say stare at your nose your God
okay am I right about religion or can we
move on okay I'd like to tell them to
cover what I he just turned
[Laughter]
also the reason why sugar is bad is it
rotted everyone's teeth Abraham Lincoln
no no George Washington lost his teeth
because of sugar that's not true you
don't know that that's [ __ ] that is
true okay they don't fluoride in the
water no toothpaste no toothbrush and
they're gonna blame sugar people's teeth
historically were better you were
chewing on meat ripping it your jaws
were better teeth removed that's not
true that is true look at old mummies
old mummies has fired teeth that's true
and then they introduce sugar into
Europe and all of a sudden all the
English mummies died at like 11. they
still had their baby teeth that's not
true they looked them up like 50. that's
not true how do you know how do you know
how old the person is
okay it was 19. but I'm saying we're
splitting hairs
19 is old you're an adult at 19. okay
miles gets all the Flack for making
things up I think you make [ __ ] up too
that's why y'all at least
bro look at this mummy yeah he's 19.
that [ __ ] is nice 19. white people get
excited about the most dumb [ __ ] song
Tell me about the [ __ ] ancient tomb
of pyramid but he has all his hair he
still has hair in his head wow they
wrapped him up so great look at that
how'd they find a way to do that they
use molasses to wrap up the mummies what
an amazing adventure okay right who
gives a [ __ ] if it's got the teeth or
not the fact is is there was way too
much food for people back in the day way
too much it was a problem it was a
problem where did all the food go then
every time the Nile got too much water
in it what is that called flooded
flooded I got you thank you son you
forgot the word for a flight yeah But
flood is not what a river does
and once that [ __ ] contracted back to
regular Nile
fruits and vegetables sprouted that's a
shaky argument when you start with
what's the definition of the uh argue
the point argue the point
the style was bad I'll do the point
[Applause]
it's one stupid thing you said
those are great tactics
miles look this up because Mark's
computer is [ __ ] broken those
obviously no it's not look at these
mommy teeth what happened to the region
around the Nile after that [ __ ] flooded
fruits and vegetables yeah it's called a
flood plain right flood plain what
happens when it floods in the
Mississippi
foreign
Fort Myers about to be Lush that's all
I'm saying no no but there's no fruits
or vegetables
[Laughter]
why does that not explain it to me does
it seem weird to anyone yeah explain it
to me it's because we got less food
okay maybe because we got less people
know which point he's saying after
Katrina why was it New Orleans full of
sprouting vegetables and plants yeah
because he's right about the Nile that
is to explain the Nile please explain
the now
River
hey we're prepared for this episode
listen look look look at these teeth
listen the Nile bro
our Jaws were more developed because we
would rip meat we would literally bite
into me
what do you mean you mean once a month
when somebody brought home meat you ate
it you didn't
know you would save me for the whole
month and then you would get another one
degree Egyptian heat where are they
preserving it didn't have salt yet
underground well you're so good yeah
yeah yeah
that's what you gotta do pull up some
titties
[Laughter]
okay it has multimedia if he doesn't
have an argument he goes and puts
pictures up there what is this a
slideshow
you got the jacket
hey I'm just saying that's all it takes
sometimes